[Music]
good to see you as always
opponent always a pleasure yeah Andy not
so much yeah you son-of-a-bitch
this is the best start to an interview
I've ever had by the way this is gonna
be your best interview ever whoa I
guarantee you that because you know why
why is that you've got a great audience
and a great sidekick Wow yes what's that
what do you got what do you mean it's
get it going let's get it going yeah oh
you're ready to do this let's talk let's
interview well okay I've never had
anyone approach it that way but let's do
it let's I got stuff I got to do okay
I got places to go we got things
together things to do yeah let's get
into it then a lot going on yes a lot
going on who does that guy you're the
only guy that comes on the show and
stops me for a long drink you've got it
before well I don't want to miss
anything you're saying but now I'm ready
I'm waste we can go seriously my mouth
is not dry at all okay I understand
hey Kevin I understand that you just
shot a movie with our mutual pal Adam
Sandler well then you shot it in South
Africa is that correct that's good
information you have I yes I was there
for five weeks five weeks I'm shooting
it's a Adam Sandler - drew barrymore
film he's a friend of mine and I've done
quite a few Adam sales I've never seen I
you're in almost every Adam Sandler
movie he puts you in a lot of these yeah
let me finish
I I'm in a lot of those films and and
it's always very embarrassing and
humiliating parts I'm starting to
realize yeah and the first one I was in
was a movie called Little Nicky where I
played a tit head the gatekeeper of hell
and I press on my head you had breasts I
remember this you had prosthetic breasts
yes all over your head prosthetic
they're real breasts okay yeah they were
no they're prosthetic you're right and
but the makeup department did a great
job and they even fill them with condoms
full of water so they jiggle then they
wait about ten pounds and I realize the
power of breasts
when I had those on my head everybody
wanted to talk to me
women guys women wanted to feel them
everybody and as a talking to me I did
keep telling hey eyes are down here so
and then at the end of the day when they
took them off nobody cared about me
right right
she was saying walking around with
breasts on your head it's a way to get
attention yeah yeah so you know I did
other movies like anger management I had
to play a lawyer how embarrassing is
that you know just go without a plastic
surgery guy I think Sandler writes these
humiliating scenes for me and then he
writes a script around that yes he tries
to think of a way to humiliate you and
then a whole movie revolves around
that's what I just said but it's come on
let's go come on we're good I'm your
friend you're my I'm your friend I'm
here to use me Kevin I've known you for
a while
[Applause]